you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with Pete
hes what's happening weirdos this is so
so fun I'm glad you're here these are uh
the please don't destroy Boys the boys
with a z I enjoy them so much on SNL
they do the digital shorts they are
hilarious they are incredible uh maybe
do yourself a favor watch a couple if
you haven't uh before you listen because
we get into the nitty-gritty on sou
nitty-gritty but you get it I'm I'm a
huge fan I think they're amazing they
actually just announced that they have a
movie coming out uh which is called The
Treasure of Foggy Mountain uh but just
go on YouTube Type in please don't
destroy and uh you don't even have to
thank me later just enjoy it it'll make
me happy happy to know to know you're
enjoying it uh only a couple things for
me to plug up top on Netflix my special
I am not for everyone is out now please
check it out it's my favorite special
that I've ever done uh and I'm relying a
lot on Word of Mouth to get the word out
so like it share it it means a lot I
worked really hard on it just kind of a
sad I worked really hard on it uh also
I'm on tour Pete homes.com Chicago's
coming up DC sold out thank you uh
couple other
things just go to pom.com I'm probably
coming to a city near you and I hope you
can be there means a lot this episode is
brought To Us by a new pizza pick which
I'm very excited about which is armra
armra you guys know I'm always on the
lookout for ways to strengthen immunity
improve my gut health improve my fitness
my metabolism enhance my hair my skin
the radiance the overall Radiance we'll
call it well I recently discovered an
incredible product called armra col
colostrum colostrum is what is it what
is that it's the first nutrition we
receive in life ever heard of it and
contains all of the essential nutrients
our bodies need in order to thrive armor
colostrum is a proprietary concentrate
of Bine colostrum that harnesses over
400 living bioactive nutrients that
rebuilds the barriers of your body and
fuel cellular health and the benefits
are crazy imagine harnessing the power
of the first nutrition you receive as a
human you reactivate hair growth and
gives you that glowing skin fortifies
gut health igniting metabolism how do
you give your metabolism a kick in the
butt Arma boom fuels Fitness performance
and Recovery I'm 44 I work out my body
aches and pains that's one of the first
things I noticed when I started taking
Arma is a faster regeneration process so
support your body support the show we've
worked out a special offer for weirdos
receive 15% off off your first order go
to tr
arm.com /we or enter weird at checkout
to get 15% off your first order that's t
r y a r m r a
arr.com SL weird we're also brought To
Us by our friends a new pizza pick which
I use every single day actually I use it
more than once a day I listen to brain
FM when I am working when I am answering
emails I've also come to start to listen
that's a weird sentence I've come to
start to listen to it in the car when I
just want my thoughts to be fueled by
interesting music that doesn't disrupt
my flow and allows me to daydream and
think and I do a lot of my best thinking
in the car so I've started using it in
the car as well what is it brain FM on
the surface seems like an app that gives
you the perfect background music for
Creative work study reading meditation
relaxation and sleep and that is true
but is much more than that brain FM's
composers work hard to create amazing
sounding music that doesn't distract and
uses their patented audio technology to
boost your mental States on demand what
does that mean that means brain FM
scientists brain.fm scientists and
composers add patterns to their music
that change the patterns in your ba
brain creating increased blood flow and
electrical activity in the brain and
increasing focus in as little as 5
minutes I swear by this guys I throw on
these very headphones open up brain FM
go to uh creative flow and drop in like
that it's a queue to my brain and it
gives it that that I need to drop in and
get work done regular music is designed
to be distracting or you're constantly
having to go back and skip a song change
a thing words suddenly there's a trumpet
get the [__] out of here trumpet or
somebody does a poem in the middle of
the song it's so nice to take the
guesswork out of it and know whatever
you're trying to do fall asleep meditate
relax unwind or focus and create brain
FM has got you covered and at science
back they have the research to back
their claims through close collaboration
with neuroscientists and a wide variety
of field experiments and testing so go
to brain. fm/ weird and you will get 30%
off one year of brain FM and start
getting more done with less effort and
unlock your best self on demand
experience the difference that the right
music can make in your life that's
brain. fm/ weird 30% off all right guys
enjoy please don't destroy get into
it holy [__] [__] we got some Pete's
piics holy [__] sh holy [__] [__]
we got holy [__] [__] we got
ourselves some
PS what are you rocking with these days
eh liquid death well that's not a that's
not a sponsor they are not paying bleep
that sorry bleep that in fact bury it
alive not very good not a sponsor I
enjoy why are you proing it you have
label out I
know like MTV crib style there's no way
to do it there you go they I they solid
life is my favorite water
okay
okay magic mine you you you boys should
drink
these yeah you're
F just do what everyone tells you to do
drink it shake it we're recording shut
the [__] up one I told you dude plus
one plus
one sorry I've been watching your vids
all morning oh and I'm in the mood for
Nude
guys you should have shook it more oh my
God there's adaptogens in this oh are
you being [__] a
[__] dude there's
a you [__] you [__] being a [__]
I didn't
Shake never been so familiar right off
the bat just really going at you guys
well guess what no you would as for for
full real like even if we weren't
recording I would tell you I'm going to
give you some for writing it's the best
this yeah this is awesome new matcha a
little bit of caffeine like about as
much caffeine as half a cup of coffee
and uh and adap which do calm you down
down so it's like an upper and a and a
downer at the same time so it keeps you
calm I just took so Aderall so is that
little bit like Aderall okay good all
right good and we have similar hair we
all kind of have similar you boys all
have like hair you should use uh modern
mammals these are just commercials this
is
fun I'm loving
this okay Start begin press no that's
all in there good okay let's do names
John Ben Ben
Martin John Ben Martin it's like
Zip Martin I said offy cam I was like
it's not a big part of the please don't
destroy branding to really drill hey I'm
John it's true we got do that group is
bigger than our individual names or our
group name no please do not destroy
please do not destroy do not disturb we
want one that we get all the time do not
disturb we had Plaza the first time we
came to La she called it do not disturb
Mikey day was like yeah do not disturb
guys are funny back to back name drops I
liked it wait what was the first one
Mike day
Mike MC coming in
hot M this is going to be a good pod
going to be a good pod we got second pod
ever that we've ever done yep yeah you
guys have minimum web press yeah we
don't do that [__] please don't destroy
for web
press wait we have so many videos online
no I know that's a severe web press but
not as not as people I got to be real
like it's a I hope it's a supreme
compliment that like I've been watching
your videos which I watch as they come
out as well but like I've never like
binged like 20 not really you know 10 in
a row and it just made me like love
comedy like so happy to see you so sweet
so happy to be riffing and I'm not
usually this you know Slappy right out
the and it's watching the tone of it is
so fun that's all I'm trying to say
thank you sweet we genuinely have all
been listening to your podcast for maybe
like 10 years shut up it's like a we
reference it in conversation like deep
episodes we really do this is a joy this
is a joy what fun it's crazy is was it
like your comedy you're young 10 years
ago well you're so much older than us
yeah that we
we can we cut back and I'm a
skeleton Cuts back and we never address
it and the rest of the interview you
don't even notice you don't address that
I'm dead yeah
yeah and there's cobwebs in my jaw like
how long has he been there and we're
answering as if you're asking questions
yes
we just take his audio out we just leave
ours
in but you how old 10 years ago you were
How old uh 18 I was 18 17 17 Martin 15
15 hey did you start 10 years ago let me
get this
ja let me get this jacket off it's as if
you haven't spoken to anyone in months
yeah so excited is it is I was touring
for a while and I was starting to lose
my nude [__] yeah dude noodle what What
markets did you hit up bud B markets you
guys into those B markets you guys
[__] up those B markets where you
can't quite move
tickets you guys you guys been
humiliated in St Louis yet we just did
St Louis sold out show it was great
show okay I guess the web pres is a
little bit higher a little bit higher
than I thought yeah you did St Louis we
did so you're doing a live tour we we
this is basically the end of it only
tell me about the
L we did a podcast yesterday and I said
uh maybe 15 words I'm not on this one
baby boy no he's about to talk I'm
finding Moses in the river man I'm
pulling you out and nursing you to help
yeah getting some lol's from the plus
one
sweet lolay laugh on the board laugh on
the
board uh go ahead uh yeah we've been
toring around since like July and what
does that look like what does it look
like to the show let me help you let me
help you
Romos oh
oh as soon as I died he's who I looked
for first I was like I'm dead not my
grandparents I'm like where's Richard
Albert I'm dead we can finally be on the
same plane again you go up and perform
sketches live you show videos what is
I'm really curious what the show looks
like yeah it's it's it's like live
sketches uh we don't really do props
we're all wearing Adidas tracksuits y uh
and uh yeah we we started doing uh
sketches live uh before we did the
videos are they sketches we've seen on
SNL or there new stuff no new stuff that
you wrote did you write this that would
be cool if our if our show was covers of
videos I actually would have zero
problem with that I don't think anyone
said that we should do it but it's a
it's a topic of con yeah yes please
thank you ka oh W there you go thank you
there you go it's weird it's not branded
in some way yeah could you sip it and
say magic mind hits the spot even though
it's
coffee was that what we yeah you drank
magic it's too hot yeah it's too hot Let
It Rock that with the lid off I'm just
saying thank you I don't it's
interesting let's talk a little bit
about that because your sketches are so
well edited do you edit them we're not
at the show uh I guess we're heavily
involved but before the show we would
edit them me and Martin would edit them
yeah yeah and John's fiance Emily yeah
okay bleep that out so
much so much of it you so much of it the
editing is is incredible and it's really
like I just watch self-defense and the
way that you're like doing the violence
in particular would you without being
too [__] NPR I am genuinely
interested in what you make of violence
physical violence a gun like it's so
funny and it's right like what like the
after the anxiety one you throw the
phone and it hits you in the face John
so funny mhm like but it's so unexpected
but it's hard to you can't just sit in a
room and go like let's do something
unexpected like right how is that coming
about is that on the set is that in the
script hits him in the face with the
phone yeah stunts you have to really
plan ahead for uh weirdly this we never
did stunts ever until this past year and
then we just got like it was like a new
toy we found that we it's a great use of
budget we throw them into yeah a budget
thing you can't really do that on it's
hard to do that on your own but as soon
as you have a little bit of a budget you
can break the bar which so [__] funny
Martin throwing that phone in my face
was a bit that when I would pitch
something in a room or something and it
wasn't funny Martin would pretend to
throw his phone at me and we were like
that would hurt more than anything your
iPhone directly the eye right here yeah
I actually think there's a rich comedy
history of like where right now
2023 where's the funniest place to be
hit I think it's one of the thermometers
in the tone of meaning remember Fight
Club I know you guys are younger than me
but like in Fight Club he punches him in
the ear and he's like oh you hit me in
the ear I remember being
like unheard of place to be hit but it
was shocking it was like legit and then
like I feel like neck had a good run hit
me in the neck throat throat is a funny
word yeah we have some throat throat
stuff
coming so you had a room bit which was
throwing the phone in the face when I
would pitch a bad joke Martin would do
that that seems unkind yeah it's a real
that's so fun Terror to work with hard
insert of Martin just kind of kind of
looking like Wind in the Willows the
mole with the with the cane just a
gentle man I can't really picture it how
often do room bits get into the sketches
is that sort of normal yeah yeah a lot
uh what the hell
man had magic mind no magic mind is I
know I have to say this actually thanks
for bringing it up magic mind does not
treat or diagnose Co 19 or uh suppress
its symptoms I've been saying that and I
shouldn't have been saying that if
anything it makes it a little bit worse
cuz you're awake and
alert so tell okay tell me just a little
like but like for real like I'm actually
interested not a stock question tell me
about the process whether it's room bits
like we could even take a sketch like um
stake out or anxiety you could pick one
and be like what was the process is it
we're under the gun we have to come up
with something fast or is or is it more
like we've been working on this for a
while stake out
was we had didn't we thought of
it we thought of
it no but a while this is where the kind
of conspiracy oh yeah we wrote that
there's three guys
generated all of our sketches are GPT I
got to help my rips it's not three guys
it's an
algorithm we had a right we came up with
that idea I think we were going to try
to do with Pedro Pascal sorry to if
that's you may look at the names on this
floor look at all the
names just swim they're swimming like
fish some of them eat other names not
cool Tom
Hanks got to laugh you're thinking
you're thinking about answer the
question I don't know it's always so
different truthfully sometimes it's
like one of us says something and the
other's like yes yes and then it's just
like easy and it comes out and we write
a draft and then like edit it but then
other times it's literally like us in
our office like truly miserable like
looking at the keyboard like
what's like an observation yeah we say
that all time observ observation
something like nightmare what is
something we might have observed ever
yeah that's literally what like our
Baseline question is when we don't have
it so much output at at that show that
it's like by the like you really reach
like the depths of like scraping at
anything yeah and what's an example of
an
observation cuz Okay very you made it
weird but like you joke some jokes are
jokes like standup jokes and some jokes
are sketches and some jokes are movies
toally and people confuse those all the
time can you think of an example I feel
like just the term anxiety is is you go
well that's a anxious yep and and look I
don't want to kill the bird but I'm just
saying it's like what if someone was
anxious and they and they should have
been like they were horrible totally but
that would that be like answer to a
question you're you're looking at your
keyboard and you go anxiety like you
know how like you're yeah exactly you
know when like you like drank the night
before and you're really nervous about
like what did I say to that person what
about if you did say a bunch of bad [__]
cuz the answer is always like dude
you're fine right you know what I mean
right I I remember that hard remember on
The Simpsons they give Barney um it's
like sympathy uh stationary that says
I'm deeply remorseful for just a bad
favorite for so okay so you guys are
going to parties and you realize that
this is a relatable thing and you go
with it yeah how far out are we coming
up with the sketches is it like SNL
style under the gun 100% it is yeah
really yeah St out that's why I was
getting tripped up on it because we
thought of that idea be a while before
we did it which is like rare like I
remember pitching it to Brady in like La
be way before we wrote it but then every
basically every other video like that
week really yeah which seems like you
guys would be sort of exempt from that
lunacy like everybody that does ssnl I'm
just like it seems so unfair that you
could have a sketch go to dress it gets
cut why don't we retool it but it's this
like perpetual motion machine that's
like no never look back and I'm like at
least the digital
guys could could but you don't no why
it's not how we do it it's CU but if it
were like how Lauren said to do it
wouldn't it become how you do it
absolutely the
boss yeah the boss man the boss man says
we do it but I think he believes in the
like it has to come together at the last
second thing yes the Mojo yes the magic
yeah a lot of feelings I have a lot of
feelings because I care about comedy and
and Comedians and I'm like we could do
this s I've said this every guest on
always so I know so I'm going to put it
to you
I'm done but does it ever occur to you
like we could do this in a a little bit
more of a Silicon Valley kind of way I I
don't want to I don't want to either
because of the Legacy and the fun it's
it's really fun yeah it being like like
4:00 a.m. on a Tuesday like yeah and
we're always so
happy yeah right right not happy no
miserable a lot of time I mean at 4:00
a.m. or when
sunrises brutal that's pretty rough that
self-defense one was a page one rewrite
at like 8 a.m. 8 a.m. we would we had to
submit it at like 12: it's almost like
sleep deprivation in Li of cocaine I'm
not even trying to be funny it's like
let's get nuts yes yeah I get it also
like you're I think Laura said this but
like you're funnier with your F like are
you
funnier during the day walking through
the hallways or are you funnier at your
sleepover at 3:00 a.m. like yeah like
Lauren has a lot of Sleepover he always
is having
sleepovers those pillows that like break
very EAS like cracking each other
up God I wish you would pick someone I
can do an impression
of Paul McCartney I know easy but that's
why I'm like don't even try CU anyone
can do it hello no
perfect hello
we have a sketch that we' wanted to do
for years which is Ringo wrote all the
good Beatles songs that's fun and then
John and and Paul are always like I like
that one
Ringo and I root TI and then and then of
course the blow is Lennon writes
Octopus's Garden and go Ringo's like I
don't like that one voice and he's like
oh really cuz you wrote it and
no okay we're talking sketches we're
having fun we're ripping we're doing
best that print it um okay so you're
doing it under the gun I think there is
I'm G to check myself after I've already
wrecked myself because it's clearly true
that like manufacturing
stakes in a like what I'm saying is is
true it's logically true like why are
you doing this at 400 a.m. yeah but when
you're in the business of creating
sleepover energy which is which is real
like you are funny as like I said I was
I was not selling out St Louis this past
weekend and you know I send myself texts
in the middle of the night you just text
yourself an idea and you look at it and
it's like 400 a.m. 500 a.m. like these
things are coming in the midst and you
know what else is disruptive is like
different time zones like I'm going to
bed at 2 but it's only like whatever
that is I'm not here to do math 11 my
body's time all those disruptions
actually are really really good and you
actually see I think you see CEO and
stuff trying to manufacture failure so
they can have something to come back
from right like I think Elon Musk kind
of quietly wants the window on the Tesla
truck to break so he can be like have a
comeback story because it sucks like you
need to have something and you guys
being young and fighting and new to the
show fighting for relevance is really
exciting like you'll be wanting to
capture this again so I think I think
this is me checking myself after I erect
myself I think Lauren is obviously right
that it's like let's I guess what I'm
saying is like deadlines don't exist
really so they make a show where they do
exist like now it does matter yes and
you guys respond to that pressure cooker
yeah like would we make better stuff if
it was not in that environment I don't
know like maybe but there is something
just appealing about lifestyle and
process wise about doing it yeah it
feels like a relic of like old show bus
shut the shut up D shut the [__] up shut
the [__] up I don't even like that as a
bit I hated that as a bit I didn't even
like saying it to you you're welcome
please tell me it was it was the joke it
was the joke to make please what do you
got B um I was just going to say that uh
I think that we like it also we have a
different space on the show than like
the cast yeah and uh that is a tough
position that they're in like we get to
edit our video and when we write stuff
for the cast we don't have to like go
out and do it that night in front of
people right you know so I don't know
like I think for writers the show is the
process is good but you know I don't
know I I who is it Martin Short no
way answer he's never been on the show
we could finally have him on the show
when does this wait when does this come
out oh we're not filming this JK uh
whenever you want any Wednesday you want
um facts ready I'm watching The Big
Short last night there's a moment in The
Big Short where they go to Vegas and
there's a huge billboard of Martin Short
which you know they didn't plan but I'm
wondering if McKay is like that's funny
it's a big short yeah it's a big short
in The Big Short in what part it's just
an establishing shot of when they go to
Vegas for the for his show it's just
like he's headlining the the Palm or
whatever and there's a big short in The
Big Short W that's good [__] so close
to being horrible okay so yes also
context for why he's calling you yes
he's so if this is coming out after
probably oh I see he's doing our Show on
in La he's going to come out as a
surprise guest that's
incredible or maybe he's calling to say
I don't want to do it boys I'm out but
it's like right and you can't help but
love it I'm pulling out I don't even
don't want to do thank you oh I don't
even have excuse I can't it's just it's
just brightness so to your point
Martin I think you're kind of getting it
both ways you have the pressure cooker
but you have the edit and I feel like
you're going to take well let me ask you
do you feel like you take more chances
because you know you can it can be a
tape cut you can take it out you can
watch it go that that didn't work right
so you I think one of the reasons why we
see these huge swings in your videos and
I say that with the most respect is
because you don't kind of have to do it
like a little play yeah have to like
read it off of cards and [__] which is
you know it's a little bit of a a a
hindrance yeah we write like four
million alts and then yeah edit it like
in insane people yeah it's it's crazy
it's it like the ability to just take
out any fat is like when you're doing a
Live sketch it's like you kind of just
it it becomes a thing where it's just
like that's just the way that intro is
of this thing and it took took us a
minute to get to the first joke yeah but
it's worth it you know in the end or
whatever but like with our videos you
can just slice out anything that feels
slow and Pace it up that's why I was
saying in self-defense like when if you
got punched it's actually a a really
funny edit to me is he hits you and it's
like a hard cut and you're on the ground
and that's very funny cuz that in itself
is a joke you know what I mean it's like
well people are supposed to fall and
they supposed to down and then when you
get hit and when you get it's all
[__] and the old lady and all of it I
forgot about the old lady no it's and
the casting on the old lady is she was
amazing excellent top tier if she was
almost for those who haven't seen it
first of all watch it but like she has
to be likable it's an old lady that's
going to get smashed into a trophy case
yeah so she has to be likable but if
she's too likable you
lose so scared of that I body slam her
into to a a glass cabinet after though
she establishes it's all status it's
like [__] chaplain she shows that she
can stop a fist play Russian Roulette so
this woman is now no longer a granny and
you now have comedic permission to BU
Checker a villain I by the way shout out
to our director Tim wil who sorry just
is about us but I remember having that
conversation I was like I think people
people are going to hate if I slam her
and he was like but she just held a gun
up to you and to herself like she is no
longer she old it's night shamalan devil
we all watch devil of course you didn't
watch go check out M Night shaan's devil
actually I did of course you did I'm not
doing a bit everyone watched devil I
have no idea what devil is it's I'm not
it's late Shyamalan really shamalan like
new elevator thing it's in an elevator
of course they seen it totally cuz one
of the people in this elevator is the
devil yeah and I don't even care it's
the little old lady it is eat [__] man
[__] I put my email address on the
screen write me up write me up drop me a
line I dare you if you're legit mad for
spoiling devil here's my real email
address I await your call
um so editing and the old lady I'm sorry
we the riffing doesn't matter tell me
okay yeah so tell me first week SNL tell
me those stories that did you have
impostor syndrome where you [__] in your
britches nope
[__] by the end of this interview
everyone's going to know John is the
balls of steel one John's got balls of
steel terrified we were absolutely oh
you were I thought you I thought you
were for real no so you rolling tell me
about showing up don't you don't you
show up and like you're early you're
like you're way too early I've heard a
lot of stories like that it they say it
starts at 11: but everybody rolls in
around 400 p.m. and you guys are just
there that's real like throughout the
week but that it was a weird kind of
postco time so [__] was kind of
different like scheduling wise and like
it stuff was a little bit more on time
yeah I remember showing up yeah yeah no
no you go I don't really remember
showing up shut up yep um you were in
the elevator an old woman was she was a
devil yeah uh we got hired with seven
other writers so it was like a group of
10 new people coming in along with like
three new cast members so it felt like
yeah a a a whole new wave of people to
be like you felt like you had a class
that help help if it was just you three
it let's be real if we're doing the
please don't destroy origin story movie
it's just you guys we can't have seven
friends also going like this is a big
deal like I can't have that I can't have
that but it helped it totally helped
because you just felt like you weren't
alone right and also these are my
enemies these are the people these are
the people that I'm going to
yeah I'm going to slowly passive
aggressively destroy their conf exactly
that's funny for you that's like that's
for you that's very funny I didn't I
didn't know you could hit that hard
brutal uh oh my God Neil Brennan said
that to me we we did did he watched my
Batman videos and he was like I didn't
know you could hit that hard I was like
I don't know how to feel
about way funnier than anything you've
ever
done oh my God I don't usually like
you exactly so you got you're in the
same office is it just you guys in one
office yeah y that's got to be that's
got to help I mean a a huge help is
having your two best friends with you
like that's that's even Beyond like the
other writers that got hired like we
could just look at each other and be
like dude I'm really [__] scared man
and then be like yeah me too and you
just go together who who uh just a
little gratitude opportunity who folded
you in nice did anybody come in and and
make an effort wow good question what if
it's just like 45 seconds of Silence
we're all just staring
no going through the names Heidi Heidi
Gardner had done our live show in New
York and was like extremely nice to us
and supportive that's great um our
friend Paul banti who directed our movie
Nate baratti no way Nate baratti yeah if
I hear anything that sounds even close
to Nate bar Nate bargi wow Nate baratti
that's so cool Paul baranti Paul banti
baratti he was the one that was like he
he was there for like 5 years already
and he was like let's just shoot
something secret style yeah no so yeah
we just got like the hard Seltzer video
which was our first video was we
secretly shot it on a Monday with like
we were just hired as writers with like
this weird like vag like and you know
maybe the videos will maybe do that at
some you do Lauren voice yeah I did not
I you can do it maybe well you know
maybe you do a video maybe I can't do
it classic Lauren hey guys you guys you
guys are funny some of your internet
shorts if you boys want to make some
lonely Islands he calls them lonely
Islands cuz that's what that means a
video online is like a Lonely Island
Paul Simon walks in we're having lunch
he plays bridge over lonely Islands have
you met Lauren he walked by me once yeah
cuz he be [__] doing that if you met
him say what you wouldn't be [__]
making fun of him if you met
him I'm glad I circled back to have you
say that total harier Bardem style you
weren't even looking at me straight to G
you wouldn't be making fun of him am I
making fun of him not at all am I no
100% JK but even that do you guys
respond to that energy the like got to
please and I'm I'm not saying this out
of school I'm saying please dad like I
do I I like like I think I would thrive
in that structure yeah Martin you're
none 100% yeah I think all of us yeah
it's nice that Dynamic right yeah did
you have that not me
dude no it's easy for me no but then
even that so we're kind of creating this
like sleepover energy and also a lot of
artists I know have that the withholding
father it doesn't mean Monster father
right it just means he's uh what what I
was on mushrooms once and I went um mom
thinks it's great dad's not impressed
this is how we learn to do our best can
you imagine how funny that would be if
we were all on mushrooms and I sang that
out
of but that's the dynamic that they're
even manufact there I'm sure Lauren in
his heart of hearts could be like I just
want you boys to succeed I love you you
know like he knows it's better to kind
of keep you a little bit wanting it with
how I don't know how I think he just has
a lot of people to take care of so it's
like I it's it's not as much I don't
think it's calculated like I'm going to
withhold I think it's like I can as a
human being take care of a million
people so I just have to you know I
don't know does he sprinkle a little
fish food on you every once in a while
like good positive good job totally I
think he does to ever like that's I
think a myth is that he's just like wow
cool you know what I mean like cool cool
video when something's good he loves it
like so tell finish the thing about desk
and JC Penny you shot it on the sneak oh
yeah but you had to get the prop
Department involved I mean that's a prop
dud Josh karp shout out bleep
and but you
you wanted to establish that so you
weren't hired as lonely Islands you know
what I'm saying you weren't hired as
were we weren't no one tells you
anything there shut up for a second
all for some reason that was worse than
shut the [__] up shut not looking at him
shut up for a second my favorite part
about that bit is that then when I do
say the thing I feel enormous
pressure yeah it's got to be good
what was your big idea you wanted to
share yeah no I literally at one point
went go go don't say go so you weren't
hired as as the digital content creators
and but you wanted to be it sounded like
that's what you we were though we were
and we weren't it was like so vague
everything there it's like there's a
million rules and there's no rules you
could we had heard like maybe through
our managers you would do videos there
and then first week when we talked with
Lauren he was like are you doing a video
this week yeah we were like do you want
us to do a video he was like he was like
you could yeah that was great you could
yeah I pictured him getting a massage
from robot arms know you boys you boys
doing a video all this week steam Tow
and you did desk you shot it on the
sneak yep and what was it how [__]
fun was it to have an edited video
and when did you show it to anybody the
scar that was the scariest thing ever
cuz it we shot
it on a Monday edit it throughout the
week and then like slowly started
inviting like writers and producers to
just watch it in the edit room yeah and
they would like laugh and be like yeah I
think this is I think this will work but
no one KN like knew at all yeah and then
yeah they told us that they wanted to
show it a dress and we were like great
even if it doesn't get on the show May
they'll put it online or something and
then it did really well address and then
it's another interesting consideration
you almost have to edit it knowing
people are going to laugh totally that's
the weirdest thing about SNL and that's
kind of comes back to the stunt thing I
don't think that's something we would
have done if it weren't for like no a
studio audience laughing like like
needing to get you need like big moves
and like physical stuff and sometimes I
can't hear the thing like it's like
bulletproof if there's like a mix
problem like oh if I you know if someone
falls through a table they're going to
laugh at that even if they can't hear if
you're on the floor at SNL watching the
show there are crew guys like shouting
and carrying giant walls and flats
behind you and you're like duing the
video game it's like paper boy it's like
Frogger for me okay and for you it would
be Halo Halo
3 would be Google Google Goggles Google
Goggles Google go right there Google
Goggles if they called Google Glass
Google
Goggles so cute let's get him Google oh
my God that feels like a Philip K dick
book cover is a baby in a carriage and
he's wearing God Philip K dick know who
that
is do you not know who Philip K dick is
no you don't need to but every of course
Total Recall oh yes yes yes it's like
you don't know Total Recall no I do but
I don't know Philip K is he like Tom
Clancy um he was a he he I believe like
wasn't even was Blade Runner Philip K
dick like all science fiction was based
off of Philip K dick who is a very far
out freaky Dicky hell yeah dude yeah
it's like you know like magazines kind
of yeah porno yeah you like porno love
it and that's the social clip
yeah that's it porno love it like
no love it so you show it a dress and it
kills yeah yeah and then they go we're
going to put on the show it was yeah yes
it was so nerve-wracking cuz it was like
it's done yeah you can't really adapt we
edit it oh my God dress we had this is a
fun little secret story I don't know if
we've told this anywhere uh but whatever
on both the podcasts you've done yeah
I hope there's some fresh
material we used all our stories
yesterday go we were like okay we have
no idea if this video is going to work
but if nothing else works the ending is
going to get a laugh because we reveal
that the whole time that we were having
this conversation in our office we were
like should we get back to work and we
turn and we're painting on an easel Alex
who is naked on our couch yeah like with
a bouquet of flowers in front of his
crotch yeah we're like if nothing else
works at least we have theend that'll
work like Alex naked whatever yeah yeah
yeah that is the only thing that got
zero at dress yeah and we were like we
like no this is the weirdest feeling
ever cuz we thought the whole time the
exact opposite would happen nobody would
laugh and then the ending would be like
nice wow look I'm you know whatever I
have hindsight I'm watching I'm like no
it's it's it's tight you know I mean
it's funny like I know we don't now you
don't need that at all yeah you
definitely don't need that ending at all
yeah well that's that's an interesting
subject is like when it comes to sketch
writing and endings that's kind of been
a classic you know usually when you
watch a sketch and it sucks it's it's
usually the ending and you guys are very
good at heightening it like one final
time would you talk a little bit about
that it's hard I mean as you know it's
like endings are the hardest part which
is like last year I feel like we did a
lot of physical endings like getting
thrown coffee on her face or something
like that or a gun comes out huge look I
I don't mean to you know oversimplify it
but it's like we we're in the business
of surprise yeah so the interns come in
this is the end of self-defense and they
go here's your coffee yeah and a lot of
people would go that's the end of the
sketch like and you know you run through
your ideas and you go like maybe it's
like a freeze frame that's kind of like
a dumb thing like you play like a
beautiful song and it's very so cuz
that's a violation of sorts it's been
this hyper violent video now it's ending
sweet you guys are like what if they
throw it in our faces scalding hot
coffee I you it doesn't it's funny to
talk this much about sketches that I
feel like you guys are doing from such
an organic placees is probably the most
analysis they've been given and again I
mean that in as a as a compliment you're
not really sitting around going like you
it feels gut based is that fair to say I
think that was like it' be nice to end
on a scream cuz that's loud and even if
they're not laughing that'll you'll hear
something we're screaming no one will
notice yeah it's kind of the same noise
as a laugh no it's true gut based and
fear based just like a lot of times
we'll talk about like okay well what's
the like emergency breakout which like
the desk hard Seltzer like title card
thing yeah was the emergency breakout in
between dress and er like how do we just
like end it Jo texted us like what about
this and we literally the graphics
Department between dress and air did
that like desk hard Seltzer it's in the
de like wow cuz that became the ending
yeah because we the the painting ending
didn't work so we were like we don't
know what to do we don't have anything
else that we second week at the show
having to like go up to a senior cast
member and be like hey you know how we
just made you get naked for this thing
we have to take you out of it I was just
going to say how hard is that to be like
it didn't work he's the coolest dude
though so he was like yeah that's
totally fine I love Alex but it was we
were like dude we're so sorry and he was
just like this is the show I've been in
this situation four million times yeah
yeah yeah you probably don't even
remember all the time you've done
something insane what about a sketch and
I mean this in the in the spirit of fun
not the spirit of bitterness sketches
that you love that didn't that didn't go
that got cut that no one ever wanted to
even shoot or maybe that you shot and
you're like that's the best thing we've
ever done and then it just goes
nowhere that's a good question I think
the only one that's ever been hard cut
like not put online or anything was our
third week where we were like really
swinging for a home run hilarious which
is we were like we said what is an
observation we had two like solid videos
now let's go what is an observation
that's what it was it's go like what are
people going to love which is always the
worst way to approach yeah it's very
Rick Ruben you shouldn't be thinking
about like what will they love you
should be thinking about what do you
love totally and I've made that mistake
yeah easy to my God all the time is
there anything worse though than I'm I'm
going to say for me I've pandered I've
been like I'm going to like sell out and
do you have I
have yeah that's your social
clip no I I I had a standup bit where I
did the Batman voice cuz I was like so
many fans like Batman and I did a joke
about taking Viagra and then not having
sex and it's like putting the bat signal
up but like Batman shows up and you're
like nothing nothing's happening yeah
and it's a fine premise but it was too
corny to be like what's going on and and
like I do it and like one person Woos
and then you're just you just feel like
a dirty you feel dirty you're like I
tried tried to reverse engineer a crowd
pleaser what was yours what did you
do uh what was the observation it was it
was something about like HBO Family
dramas or something but it was like it
was like not specific enough to one kind
of Trope I don't even really remember it
was like the kind of like Prestige like
miniseries like the Nicole Kidman ones
yeah from that I can't even remember it
was like at a time where HBO had like
three shows that were kind of family
dramas okay and we were like have you
noticed how like HBO has all these like
family dramas and like that was the
observation it's like everyone's talking
about this like it it's front of mind
which is like that's death yeah yeah but
it's
also I mean what happened with Seltzer
you guys are going everyone's making
Seltzer but that was just came from JC
Penny har Seltzer would be a funny
phrase and then it happened to be
something that reverse engineer did
that's so perfect because you thought of
something kind of absurd and silly but
then you gave people a way in which is
it's it's one of the few sketches you
guys have that has like a very clean
expositional someone goes since white
Claw is doing so well everyone's doing
it but you need that and now you've kind
of like snuck in we just wanted to say
JC Penny yeah Mart like wrote it on a
list of like what are some ideas and it
was like JC Penny har Seltzer that's
funny and then that was it that is
hilarious yeah and fantastic okay so the
family drama thing didn't work no did
not work we've also like I remember one
big failure at table was we wrote
something with a ton of celebrity cameos
where that was kind of like the whole
thing it was like a song like boy band
thing where it was like and Seinfeld is
here and this person's here right and I
remember just feeling everyone was just
like that's a kind of Pander like you're
just trying to make a big thing you're
digging in your toy chest if I was at
SNL I was like do you think guy Fier
would do you know you'd be wrong all of
these quote unquote mistakes are like so
success adjacent yes yes that's so true
that's so true and if they worked I
could and and we all could this is the
mystery of Comedy we could all see all
of these things being like and that was
our big and
thats totally and Seinfeld did and and
it's like whoa and that's going back to
like Lauren being way Kinder than you
think he is he knows that too so it's
like what something like that that bombs
it's like nobody yells at you but it's
just like yeah you know that won't work
right and that's it and you kind of just
like move on learn your lesson and then
like I think that's what makes it in
comedy as a whole
infinitely explorable and why people
want to do it the rest of their lives
cuz like golf or rack racket ball I
guess like there are certain things
where it's like it doesn't matter how
much you play it yes you might get hit
in the face with the ball the best
player in the world just ends up in the
sand trap and you're just like that's
Golf and that's comedy so would you talk
a little bit about humility I mean is
has does it help and inform like or are
you just rolling with it yeah bombing I
think is like the most important thing
you can do we were just talking about
this Howell like it feels like Comedians
and and musicians and people who perform
live have like the longest shelf life
yeah because there's no way to like
trick a live audience or something like
you can't you'll feel it if it's not
being received properly yeah so I don't
know that is pulled straight from my
brain it's like writing a book I'm
looking at Gary Goldman's book that's
hard because you're just in a vacuum but
like going knowing you have to go up on
stage that night you're like I got to
cut this line yeah
not laughing at it hurts it's like
Junior High gets condensed like the
horror of Junior High get cond into a
5-second feeling in your gut yeah like
no we didn't like that what you just did
horrible yeah and especially what you
were saying about like when you see how
hot the laughs can get sometimes when
I'm doing standup and it's like a new
set or something and I get a 10 laugh
it's almost a curse cuz you're like [__]
now I know what a 10 sounds like and I
don't think there's any more 10 I don't
think I have any more 10 totally I put
my 10 in the opening five minutes and
now I'm just now you're chasing it and
you know the mark You're not hitting oh
God which is why you close on your best
joke cuz you don't want the humiliation
it sucks it sucks too in a sketch when
the premise line gets the biggest laugh
and then it's just like slow downhill
but isn't that the that's that's again
on The Simpsons a show it was on ni
nickel you'd put a quarter in and you
could watch
the oh cool it sounds cool oh it was
like a long Tik Tok yeah um sorry that
was ridic thank you for that laugh I
appreciate that that was such a stupid
old guy young guy it's like a long time
I was going to do a joke where I didn't
know what the Simpsons in so I felt it
that was the area that that was the
observation yeah yeah love what these
comedy guys don't know the Simpsons but
remember crusty comes in and he has huge
ears and he's like I got to clean my
ears and he holds up a giant Q-tip yeah
and then he
says it's four more minutes of this like
just like that that's like when you get
a laugh dude I remember dudes I remember
when I was in summer camp and we did
there was like a talent night and me and
my friend Nick did that sketch where you
put your legs your hand your arms in the
pants and you look like you know a tiny
person and you do like a dance or
something the lights come up vivid
memory zero laugh I'm thinking like when
the lights come up and they see us and
then I do like an offensive Richard
Simmons impression oh zero laugh and I'm
swinging I'm going I'm Richard
Simmons zero and then the rest of it is
like sort of fat Shamy like the other
guy was like stuffed with and he's going
I'm like nothing oh that stinks D it
actually yeah it does stink and I'm glad
like you said bombing is like the best
thing you can do is like I remember in
um I don't subscribe to this advice or I
don't endorse it but like in Judy
Carter's stand-up comedy of the book the
first exercise is go out and bomb on
purpose yeah my counterargument to that
is Sweeties you don't have to try toally
try your best go for the go go for the
goal totally go up and go I'm Richard
simm [__] washing it yeah that's
valuable too like yeah it's fun you have
that story forever now it's really funny
like bombing is just that thing where
it's like it you're okay and it like
really does allow you to go like I know
what I liked about this thing originally
which is why I tried it and usually you
can going back to your point of like why
didn't you retool stuff it's like you
kind of can like through a back door way
of like that thing that I like about
that I can use that for another yeah
extract it what is I'm not even making
fun what is the observation like what
was the core of yeah like I mean blind
consumerism is always going to be kind
of funny like like people chasing I'm
talking about the Seltzer one that's
funny it's funny how blatantly people
are like it that's their version of
trying to make a home run like me doing
the Batman voice or whatever totally
what is the dynamic in the group like
here let me let me really toxic yeah Al
Sigma Alpha wait two alphas and a
sigma not a Zeta not a beta a sigma what
is a sigma Sigma is just like the middle
somewhere in the middle you're kind of
nothing you're nothing it's fine it's
okay here's my here's my real and it's a
leading question so forgive me is there
what is the business sense like in this
group I don't mean money I mean like
are all three of you on the same page or
is one of you like a pure artist that's
like I don't care man it's about the
laughs or were you all kind of like we
would like to do SNL We would like to
have a YouTube presence we would like to
do movies are you all on the same page
or is there or is there like um I don't
know you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
totally I think the it's a boring answer
but I kind of think yes all three on the
same page would you talk a little bit
about no no thank you next
question no I sorry you guys said the
Holocaust didn't happen would you talk a
little bit about I mean just look before
we were
roll okay you don't want to answer that
one Dodge now would you talk a little
bit about work work ethic here's here's
I am 44 and I do sometime o cut back to
the SP comes out the spider is also
old but you know we older people do tend
to kind of look back at the younger
people and go like in general like you
don't see what you see is a lot of
whatever yeah like a lot of like whoops
I'm famous or or like of course I should
be famous like just a lot of kind of
like listlessness and I and I understand
I think it's a product of our culture
I'm not I'm really not blaming the
people yeah but when it comes to like
good oldfashioned like hit the bricks
tore grind it out polish it work it um
and and and I hate the word networking
but like find relationships and and and
amplify it and and ask Jo for an end
just talk a little bit about work ethic
and and and what that means to you and
and when you've done things that you
that were hard for you to do but were
good for the group
right h so
boring just kidding so boring I'm
rich more more yes no I it's it's a good
question I think like going back to what
you're saying about like it's just not
sexy to be like I had a clear list of
goals and every day I like worked
towards them when aiz did this show I've
said this before I I know what you're
say yeah we've all listened to
well you know how much this mattered to
me so you I think if I remember
correctly you were like you had kind of
a calculated like like as scent and he
was like took issue with that is that
what different it's different bus school
wasn't that a part of it I think I think
part of aiz is lore is that he majored
in marketing and I think that helped and
I think look I'm not this is not shots
fired to aiz it's all respect actually
but I vividly remember being
24 in a bar in in New York after a show
and he was 22 and Dane cookie just sold
out Madison Square Garden and I think
this is admirable that's why I don't
mind saying it yeah he kind of casually
was like okay danne is whatever danne
was 30 yeah he's like okay I have eight
years to sell at Madison Square Garden
he just kind of casually mentioned
that's a good now I've seen you can do
it I would like to do it and then he
[__] did it and when did the Pod and
look I'll take his word for it he says
he didn't say it which I've
misremembered things so I'll go with him
and he didn't say but I'm like why why
if if he is denying it and he did say it
I'm kind of like why isn't it cool I
think it is cool to
go be 22 and go I want to sell out
Madison Square Garden cuz look I don't
mean to sound like [__] Tony Robins
but like that is the first step if
you're going I will will never sell out
Madison Square Garden you won't like
[__] facts like that's the realest
[__] and I I've told the story a million
times but I remember being like
backstage doing some show and I was like
I'll never have a TV show this was on
crashing I was like I can't picture
myself on the side of a bus and and a
voice in my head was like don't worry
you never will be and I was like [__] so
then I changed it and I started I'm not
talking about manifesting I'm talking
about green lighting and saying it's
okay to want what you want I don't think
the universe was like and now we will
honor his wishes but if I'm like I can't
see it it's not going to [__] happen
that's just like basic selflove stuff
totally so what does that what do what
does that make you think it I think it's
like we were always goal oriented in the
way that you're talking about we just
like it made it easier to go like I want
to make a video by in two weeks I want
to have this video done yeah and like
little by little with your goals like
you can kind of start dreaming bigger
because you realize that stuff is
attainable when you keep going and it's
just ordinary people that are doing it
it's like it's like gross feeling and
embarrassing because it's like I think
that I have I am entitled to like some
kind of career or something like right
there's like an arrogance there is an
arrogance to and it's grotesque totally
you but it's also like yeah you're
you're never going to do it unless you
have some element of right you have to
say yes this what is this a [__]
still on Instagram with a quote but you
have to say yes for it like you do so
you guys what is you're doing I this is
so weird and I never even think about
this but I I took a class at the end of
my senior year of college that was about
like Systems Science and about how like
if you have systems in place to achieve
the things that you want to achieve
that's the only way you'll do them like
like how like
like motivation and all of these like
lofty kinds of things like just don't
work unless you're like systems systems
like something real like three times a
week I will meet up with these people
for three hours and we'll read these
things like that is the only way that
you'll continue to like I [__] love
this and I wish it wasn't embarrassing
because I think a lot of you guys must
get it all the time it's so embarrassing
I felt really embarrassed just saying
that no that's why I'm giving you a hard
thank you because I think the reason why
people come up to you guys and go dude
how do you get SNL it's cuz they think
you w a Callin show you know what I mean
like well we called John's dad and we
said and we said hey it's time and he
said okay cuz your dad was the writer
producer producer yeah oh I'm sorry
producer well yeah it was as easy as
just a phone call it's time yeah but
that's [__] too so that's your
version of radio calling show is oh it
must be some sort of nepotism or
something yeah but it's like it's funny
with that because it's like the
conversation surrounding nepotism is one
that we understand it's like oh yeah
that that like we are extremely lucky to
have the connections and to have just
seen family members go in this business
like that is huge way more helpful we
talk Val and I talk about that with our
daughter we like all of my friends yeah
followed their dreams yeah and they're
verying degrees of super famous or
whatever but like she will grow up like
in a brothel of people that like tried
to get tried to do it and we don't have
that it's I'm glad you said that because
like people think it is someone going
like my son is ready to be on the show
is horseshit and systems I I just I
can't thank you enough for that answer
cuz that's real yeah and it's very the
war of art did you read the war of art I
just read it on the plane to La did you
listen to it no I read the whole thing I
do a great Steven press impression
resistance coming in the back door
telling you you're a lazy [__] you got
to get in front of your keyboard was the
work good it doesn't matter that's
someone else's problem you showed up and
the Muse ate your [__] like it's like
that I love but Dad actually gave we I
did the show at this old theater in New
York called the annoyance with my friend
I remember the annoyance yeah and um we
just bombed [__] [__] and my dad saw
it and like this is going back to like
how helpful it is to have somebody that
knows it he made us read the war of Art
and uh Steve Martin's born standing up
and it was like yes okay got it that's
the true that's not nepotism that it's
just like a dad really help he obi-1 you
yeah homework but so you what were the
systems that you put in place did you
guys routinely we met up every day for
like five years can I just say it's so
you said boring earlier that's the right
word you know when you learn how a magic
trick is done you go there was a dove in
his pants and it's boring and lame it's
the same with like writing great
sketches getting on SNL it's like we met
up every day and we still
do so boring it's so boring wouldn't it
be great if you were just like [__]
Martin does I
Wasa with JC Penny wow dude what a
disappointing Spirit Journey JY
Benny
puking he got a two-minute video out of
his ey trip and he's never been the same
no never been the same so when you meet
up same time yep no no but every day
yeah I would say a changes of like you
know if we hung out the night before or
something and it's like a had jobs and
stuff so right right I was working at
the 14th Street Y in New York in the
afternoons like a counseling little kids
or whatever and it was funny it was like
I feel like you had jobs like this in
New York where it was like 10 other
comedians working there yeah well I had
an office where it was a bunch of comics
and we all met in the same place which
was sort of a version of what you were
doing although often it was just me
sitting there I use that office so much
more than everyone really oh yeah I was
napping in there but when it was a
little group yeah that made a difference
so a lot of comics worked at the Y yeah
but then after we got out I remember we
would just keep cuz we all went to NYU
we would keep sneaking in and using
their rooms to write and they the staff
got so mad at us at a certain point they
were like you can't because it was like
kids there like that were like you know
locking the doors at night so they like
knew us they're like you guys can't just
keep this is like illegal you're like
you've been graduated for like five
years now but we would just go into like
the film we would go to Tish and go down
to their uh like film screening rooms
because they had computers that you
could connect to a big projector so we
would we call it the lab and we project
whatever we're writing onto the thing
we'd all sit there and you just writers
roomed it yeah also acknowledging that
the immense privilege that we went to
NYU I don't mean to be like oh yeah we
were it's okay we drop names here we
don't check
privil that's actually
discouraged like kind of like noting it
calling it out we we don't like
that no but okay I hear that and I'm I I
think that's 100% accurate and valid and
just a c it's it's it's a it's a point
next to it it's not negating it how many
[__] kids are going to NYU that
aren't taking advantage you know what
I'm saying it I think that's something
losers just [__] losers stupid
losers we actually were surrounded by
what why is dead beats worse dead beats
and
losers is brutal the only one that's we
is
bums bunch of bums
actually hateful yeah yeah you couldn't
use a cell phone in the 80s if you
didn't say bums bums everywhere that's
what unlocked it that was the face Ida
can I go pee yeah of course I got two
others you're going to leave yeah I'm
got to go pee I have to go so bad too
but it's okay and he peed before the
show I'll just talk to Martin yeah you
guys have feeling need some one-on-one
what
is is there different roles you're all
doing the same thing I think when people
are looking at a group and there is a
quieter one you're like this is probably
the director I'm not saying that that's
the case you're in the videos I never
would have guessed that you're a quieter
person cuz you're exactly you're all
hitting hard but like is that true in
the dynamic are you a little bit more of
the steady Yeti I think I think when we
started I was way more comfortable
writing than performing and I don't
think that that's I think we just have
like developed together so we all kind
of have very similar skill sets yeah
like sensibilities yeah yeah how did you
guys meet was it at
College we we were doing
standup I'm keeping my mouth but uh we
were doing standup at NYU met through
that started going to mics together um
what do you mean at NYU Oh you mean
while you read nway yeah there wasn't
like a stand up there was a club there
was like a club that uh what's it called
uh Aster Place riots okay it was a a
really good [__] time badass was it fun
it was fun it was fun it was like Rachel
senet uh was in it I don't know if you
know her she just did that movie bottoms
she's so funny okay uh so it was like a
a space like the university is
acknowledging like a lot of comedy and
performers to come let's give them a
club there was this kid uh who lived on
my floor freshman year who was just like
I think I think he auditioned for all
the Improv and sketch groups and didn't
get into any and he was like I'm going
to start a standup thing that's like you
know what that is so when I was in
Chicago I didn't get into all the Improv
teams and then you found there was
always a place where the broken toys or
you know what [__] Broken Toys the
people who don't audition well in the
hallowed Halls of Chicago improv and get
a little nervous they would go to in
that case it was like the playground so
this was like a place to catch the
people that were
not whatever killing it in the regular
way well I was both so um you go pee
okay I'm gonna go no I meant that in a
loving way okay
bye what if you left I would never
forget you just never don't don't commit
to the bit we're enjoying
you pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by a supplement
that has literally changed both mine and
Val's Life by helping us uh promote the
production of neurotransmitters that's
such a fancy way to say we've been
looking for a way to boost dopamine to
boost oxytocin and we have found it and
to fall asleep and we found it from our
friends at first person first person
designs Precision targeted supplements
made with functional mushrooms so you
can feel good knowing it's all 100%
organic mushrooms that aim to stimulate
the body's natural production of
scientific uh sorry specific
neurotransmitters that trigger
activities like energy mood and sleep
golden hour for we call it the good mood
pill you throw it down Tunes you into a
sense of Joy connection and relaxed
presence we were just on vacation we
were taking them every day also when I'm
just trying to get work done when do you
not want to tune into a sense of Joy
connection and relaxed presence you're
not sedated you just feel good I noticed
the difference the first time I took it
and without about 15 minutes and the
effect has built with time the more I
use it I also use their Sunbeam which
maximizes productivity and creative
activities by tuning into an inspired
focused mindset by supporting the body's
natural production of the dopamine to
activate the brain's motivation and
reward system so dopamine isn't just a
good feeling it's actually what
motivates us to get stuff done so if I'm
sitting down to work in the morning two
sunbeams about 10 15 minutes kicks sin
boom you're in the zone and Moonlight I
take every night to fall asleep so you
got golden hour for oxytocin you got
Sunbeam for dopamine and Moonlight for
wonderful sleep for the Gaba
neurotransmitter and there's no uh
melatonin I don't know if you know that
I'm really against melatonin supplements
and I love that it's not made with that
it's really really wonderful 100%
grainfree organic mushroom as well as
highly curated blend of neutraceutical
so excuse me it's not a 100% mushrooms
but it is mushrooms that are organic and
a highly curated blend of neutraal first
person is a game changer start improving
your brain health and cognition with
first person get 20% off your first
order by going to get firstperson decom
and use code weird these statements have
not been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration these products are not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease were're also brought
To Us by our friends at next Evo you
guys know I love CBD but the biggest
problem that I encounter when I'm
telling people that they should try CBD
is one they don't feel it it doesn't get
into them and they don't know how to get
the dose so how do you know how to do it
right next Evo Naturals has absolutely
figured it out our bodies don't absorb
CBD oil well so when you reach for
oilbased CBD products you could be
absorbing as low as 6% of what's on the
label but next Evo Naturals have Dei
developed a proprietary water soluble
form of CBD clinically tested multiple
times which has proven to work faster so
you know how you feel almost right away
and absorbs four times better so you
stay calmer or sleep better during the
stressful time of year which let's be
honest this is a stressful time of year
and we need to Dess and that is what I
love the most is their stress gummies
that have ashwaganda adaptogens to help
you ease and flow and get low get low
and cozy and good and the CBD that's
absorbing four times faster it's not
well known but CBD isn't actually an oil
but other companies often dissolve it in
oil because it's a cheap and easy way to
make tinctures and gummies CBD only
works though when your body absorbs it
so next Evo did the hard work and
created a unique Pro proprietary water
soluble form of CBD CBD and their
products absorb faster better and are
actually quite delicious with no hempy
aftertaste with so many choices you can
trust the brand that has the data next
Evo products are proven to absorb four
times faster four times better with than
most oil-based products and they work
fast with absorption starting in just 10
minutes now you can try their uh brand
new Extra Strength daily Wellness CBD
gummies that are two times stronger than
regular strength those are dope Extra
Strength daily Wellness CBD gummies if
you've tried CBD in the for before and
you had your heart broken give it
another go next Evo is incredible don't
waste your time with oilbased CBD that
might not work upgrade to better
solutions from next Evo go to next
evo.com
neext
v.com and use promo code weird to get
25% off that's 25% off at neext evo.com
promo code weird all right everybody
let's get back to please don't
destroy um we were talking about the
different dynamics that Martin initially
was a little more comfortable writing
uhhuh and then I think this is what I
want you to do is address the idea
people are going to be like you guys
were the clown boys and he was sort of
like the uhhuh you know what I mean like
in uh Lonely Island yeah it's like yorma
and Andy right and then um AKA AKA it's
like oh you're the AKA right you're
you're going to direct the movie but
that that isn't right right no I I also
just have no sense of cameras or any of
that [__] no that this is exactly what
I'm saying like people are just going to
project the past onto you guys but what
I'm getting a sense is it's not it's
like you guys are all performing you're
all writing he was performing at the
what riots at NYU Master RS no I did
Hammer cats oh cool yeah which was uh
the sketch group there where I bet uh
Ben and then Ben was doing that the
master Place rid with you yeah yeah and
then they started a show and then asked
me to do it with them so you didn't do
uh stand up no I think it's a do you
still like it sinful art it is P alcohol
is a sin yeah what a great little button
on that sketch alcohol is a s uh right
oh it's at the end of anxiety Martin do
you still like standup or is it I mean I
love watching it I don't I don't do it
anymore uh it was just so much more it
it was so terrify like doing open mics
in the city was like being 18 was yeah
that's tough harrowing yes and in what
way like did things happen no it was
just like nobody there uh uh liked me
you know it was just like I didn't want
well no no I it just was hard to like I
was just I'm not like that social or
whatever and and his act was really
racist yeah
yeah but they didn't like you on stage
but they also just you you're not like
you weren't a chill hang in the scene no
yeah maybe they didn't like me as a
wrong thing to say people were very nice
and and uh good to me I didn't know how
to hang out after I'm so with you yeah
it's it's like that's a certain type of
personality and honestly feeling like a
misfit even in a group of Misfits is
kind of can be a good thing it can draw
you to what you'd rather be doing which
is why I ask you if you still do it it
it's like once you discover sketch and
community and collaboration it can be
pretty hard to go back to the village
underground yeah and just like be like
my balls my balls are too low for a
young
man this guy knows what I'm talking
about H it that that's why I never did
it it's way too scary yeah I get it even
though I love it yeah it's one of those
things that I'm like I'm glad an
alternative didn't present itself sooner
you know what I mean I had already been
doing it long enough and then I
discovered it do you still do it no um
I'm hoping to to make my break away from
these guys pretty soon yeah yeah but
what's intolerable yeah but you are
friends they're friends on the show
because you're friends in real life yeah
and that Dynamic has been Rock and
strung yeah yeah yeah we're staying at
the same house right now by choice and
are you doing a movie is this something
you can talk about no we can't really
talk about it but we did we we already
did it we did it with your friend Jud
hsh Jud H yeah love Jud hirs yeah he's a
great dude I wouldn't I went into the
house uh and there was a little boy who
was like why do all these people keep
coming in our
house strange man use your
bathroom she was like so you know how
Pete tells jokes for a living she start
to explain
it sometimes my thing with Kate who
rents the house she always asks who the
guest is and she never knows who they
are it's so funny and I I I don't know
why it
hurts every time you're excited about
exited so please don't destroy guys from
MN Allen she's like I don't know you
never know them it's like Gary Gan G Gan
no no why do you
ask it kills me it really kills me funny
all right so let's talk about other
stuff yeah there's three of you so the
chances are greater ever see a ghost no
you have I saw
ghost like I just saw a
ghost I have I have one I didn't see a
ghost but I grew up in Savannah Georgia
which is the most haunted city in
America I can't handle it have you ever
been there yes yeah just that droopy
even the trees look like they're dealing
with trauma yeah oh yeah just like
[__] sad wet trees yep well
relax home but so we we my mom and I
moved around a lot we moved like every
year and uh one time we moved into this
like old it was a condo or an apartment
in a converted Hotel on the waterfront
like this giant Pink like beautiful on
the outside but kind of shitty like on
the inside Hotel yeah and there were all
these rumors about how it was haunted
and uh like we were living there for a
while it's like a vaguely spooky what
ever creepy grounds keeper guy like
classic stuff and everything you're
saying is classic including it was just
you and your mom yep so you are your
parents divorced yeah that's par for the
course I've said this many times but
every haunting is I had just left Henry
you know what I mean like and I took the
boys it's always and they can't get away
it's like the echo of [__] trouble
are chasing you or something which I
don't believe but like it's it's a weird
anomaly keep going and then uh every
night for like two weeks the fire alarm
started going off in the night and
everybody would evacuate the building
and the fire department would come and
we would be like what's going on they
would be like uh we don't know it's like
faulty system or whatever and then after
like a certain point we're like what is
going on like you have to tell us what's
going on and one of the guys was like
well the signal is coming from the
basement but the basement
the basement is is locked and nobody can
get it I don't like it and it was
like I don't like that I don't like it
and my mom also says she saw a chair
fall down in the middle of the night God
damn it no one but we had cats so it
might have just been a cat oh cats are
the ghosts of the pets it was a cat
brother yeah cats are ghost pets that's
creepy it was very it was very spooky
are you open even you Martin who's never
seen one if you saw one would you just
be like there must be any other
explanation or could it be a spirit I'm
open to ghost you're open to ghost I
would love to see a ghost well that's
what I be great that's what I'm saying
about nuts you're on a plane and there's
hello on the window hello M that's the
thing about people that have said
they've seen them where it's like I am
totally open to it but if I saw a
[__] ghost my life would be different
forever I would go like like none of
this would be happening care there's a
[__] ghost like I me that's crazy so
what about UFOs that that's like you
know what I mean UFOs are ghosts for
Science and proof nerds yes true you
know what I mean go on
youtube.com yeah and watch a Lonely
Island
about top UFO sightings and there's some
that like everyone saw and there's like
multiple angles of a giant black
triangle and then it just Zips away and
everyone's like and we're just like see
this is why I I don't think it's true I
think if you saw a ghost you your brain
you know compartmentalize it and you
just like it's like child birth there's
a part of the brain that deletes the
trauma of childood I think you just
can't handle it it's not convenient so
you just go back to eating nacho cheese
which is why in the new Indiana Jones
when he's like they ask him if he
believes in God or something like I've
seen stuff that doesn't make sense and
it's like Indie you watch The Arc of the
Covenant open and kill 30 Na and you're
still like I'm an
agnostic what the [__] but that's
actually kind of true we don't we can't
hold on to Al Gore's inconvenient truths
I I guess I'm
also that was
awesome great I feel like I'm
like I'm also thinking about horror
movie Ghost yeah if it was a ghoul
somebody's face like a lady that drowned
and she's back yeah yeah yeah all the GS
by the way oh that's a that's a
derogatory against Ghost if you see a
ghost and go don't and you go a cool
like that they would be upset guess what
don't give a [__] they hate it look they
have nothing to lose they're already
dead they'll come for you yeah so you're
saying if he saw a ghoul it would what
that is what I'm saying it would stick
with me forever but if I saw a just a
figure an enti confusing yeah I would I
think I could compart what about
psychics you boys ever go to a psychic
and have your minds blown wouldn't go no
wouldn't go I would I haven't yet I
don't know why you look like you could
be read by a psychic extra extra easy oh
definitely I something readable about my
dreams are like just so parallel to
whatever I'm anxious about it there's no
it's so easy to like you's going I wake
up and I'm like yeah it's oh I no
analysis needed no it's not like the
bird represents fear it's like oh I was
like bombing on us like I was oh yeah
I'm scared about that like yes uh what
about almost die ever almost die you I
bet all three of you haven't almost die
no oh god really no never sucked away by
a rip tide hot air balloon going to
towards those power lines have you I
don't think I these are all
real no I I mean my almost die story
isn't great but I was holding my dad's
hand walking in the beach and like a a
wave like almost sucked me out and he
pulled me out and I was like covered
head to toe in sand and I remember it
but what's weird is I remember it in the
third person like I remember watching it
that happened to PE but I remember being
in the shower and there was sand in my
mouth and I was like like completely oh
my God total
Sandman no I mean no what about your a
what's your Afterparty technique do you
guys go
yeah yeah yeah we go uh Aderall uh you
take Aderall to the party no you you're
so hyped up from the show that it's like
uh it it does a little bit feel like
work yeah it is I've been to a couple
and they're not they didn't feel chilled
to it's not what you think an SNL
Afterparty is going to be
ever are you Kidd is that
short take it take it take it take it
take it
like [__] spam risks know my phones
on do not disturb but they they call
again wow [__] damn God damn it so
it's not fun no we have it can be yeah
uh but a lot of times it's like truly
like unwinding from a crazy week of
course yeah I get it it's fun seeing
friends come like when Brady comes to
the Afterparty or my fiance or something
like Paul McCartney Paul Simon post
post Malone yeah I'm more of a pre
Malone guy oh [__] yeah dude yeah we'll
fix it in post [__] yes nice nice
Knuckles yeah Knuckles nice there we
go okay all right oh I had I had the
next area that's right I'm
hosting I'm coasting and
hosting um it seems like it's such a
there's so much energy involved are you
guys being careful with your bods like
when it comes to booze and like are are
you like regiment what I'm asking is
like are you the new generation that is
going like I'm not going to necessarily
get [__] up or drink in the office
because it's like we're going for it or
are is it still kind of like a party
Smith Smith
spere it's not really on Saturdays we'll
party like after the show cuz you're
unwinding yeah yeah but like during the
week it's you can't really be hung over
and do it do the days yeah we work like
like Finance bro hours yeah so it's like
yeah literally it's like a lot to handle
but yeah um yeah a lot of a lot of
opiates yeah amphetamines yeah yeah yeah
that's I mean you mix them called the
Buddy of the elf yeah which is it's just
I I don't mind saying it nothing better
nothing better you don't drink anymore
no I don't and and that's been good for
my comedy I guess that's kind of what I
was getting at but that like it's a it's
a confirmation bias I'm like that works
for me have you guys figured that out
yet but some people do drink and it
works for them I didn't drink during the
pandemic at all and did it I liked it a
lot yeah uh but then SNL was like I
thought I was like [__] I really cuz I
was like 23 we did this show downtown at
this bar called vaugh so like every
Wednesday I was getting like [__] it
was just like a party after the show
yeah and I was like I gotta stop that
and then so I just stopped and was like
oh I'm just not going to drink the whole
time because like why would I you know
what I mean right and I liked it what
about like are you finding a a
correlative a correlative correlative
Brady Brady BR Brady
corative you just said what I
said it was correct correlative yeah
that's not it correlative correl
correlation yeah between like any
behaviors and creative
like I'm one of those guys that like if
I can't think go for a walk or somebody
this is going to sound stupid but like
juggling somebody said like bouncing a a
basketball is way better than like just
kind of staring at your keyboard some
physical disruption basb you found any
links between yeah yeah that help
definitely get out of my head that's a
stepen pressfield thing he's like why is
it you think about a sketch hard at your
desk then you go for a walk and he's
like there's something bring te still
working on it effortlessly yeah that's
the best and that kind of goes with his
theory that like art wants to exist and
there's something kind of like this is
adding a story to it that is sort of
like Divine or it like has a will
because it is still going even though
thinking hurts and totally efforting
sucks but like you're just brushing your
teeth and you go like oh it was always
there it was just working its way up it
just needed to come out I do the 12330
which is 12 incline 3 mph
for 30 minutes 12 on a treadmill on a
treadmill you're on a treadmill and you
do what 12 inclines so you're like
walking up a hill Oh [__] 3 m hour for
30 minutes and it's been like we did I
did it all tour we like all did kind of
12330 Jes and cow it's nice you're just
sweating buckets by the end and it's
like I feel like I have to do it now
yeah all right I'm glad I asked yeah I
I'm a I'm a big treadmill person too I
know I should be walking outside I
suppose but I'm like I don't have to
watch out for [__] cars I know godamn
I wish I did Marty's a runner he runs
outside big time all right you don't
mind dodging cars and foxes like like
we're staying in like the hills and it I
I'm like almost hit by a car five times
I was going to say no one's stopping at
those stop signes up there you go to you
got to be soups care um tell me a name
droppy story go ahead [__] do it just
tell me that weird story you know you
have it [__] just tell it um just
[__] tell it it's okay everybody
loves it [__] Ramy Malik comes in and
grabs your nips just tell me tell me
when he h out with Nick Rutherford once
that was pretty
cool that is the best answer and I went
through my brain and I found Nick's face
and I was like I love Nick I love it but
I think people are looking for like Vin
Diesel it was a real thing though
because it was at the SNL 40th my dad
got to take us his whole family and he
brought Nick as a date no Nick was
writing there and it was like Prince was
there Jay-Z was there and I just was so
excited that I got to talk to Nick
Rutherford really yeah like a true
comedy I love that great answer but has
anyone blown you away I I remember I
think it was melany I was like who gave
you who blew you away and it was John
Ham which is funny cuz yeah John is such
a presence in the scene we've all kind
of gotten used to him but it's but like
this is Mad Men John Ham and hosts and
everybody's [__] a brick anybody
make you [__] a
brick or excite you Brady what Tony Hawk
Tony Hawk T Hawk met Tony Hawk that was
extremely cool Paul R was aw amazing I
mean melany yeah we did a video with
Taylor Swift that was crazy was she fun
awesome yeah she was awesome I always
want to know what are they eating do
assistants run in with some sort of
weird baguette it's always it's always
more normal than you'd think yeah it's
like it's not like whoa look at this
it's like she was just like oh my God
yeah that's so funny eating like a salad
like yeah yeah would love to do that
like that's like like it's so not like
yeah I I based that on I think it was
Tom Papa told me that he was doing a
movie with Matt Damon and they just
brought him Paul F Tomkins Paul F
Tomkins and the blue ice cubes yep you
guys are fans
as I always think of that story because
think that was E3 Live which is a blue
green algae that has a lot of protein
and vitamins so I'm always like what are
these guys eating but that's on set you
got to keep it on set you got to do it
keep it light all right what about uh
[__] God you guys listened to this
podcast this is your uh you know this is
our time let's talk about it any
thoughts
on I never make it to the end of the
podcast I don't know the first 30 are
awesome first 30 is great the rift the
rift get through the rift jump and then
click it off as soon as I'm like
Jesus it's like
yikes yikes no I love I love the those
parts of the conversation I like what
should we what I don't know no pee
again we all know you're doing ketamine
bumps out there guys I uh uh I believe
I'm a Believer in what I don't [__]
know um that's okay this isn't this
isn't Martin time you're not on the spot
like it's just an opportunity for us to
talk about like it's [__] crazy that
I'm in here and you're in there but
we're also here yes and no one's talking
about that it's like one of the weirdest
things like I'm in here all the time I
got stol the other night I was on the
road not selling out St
Louis what
theater theater oh what club yeah I love
what theater no no no what theaters I
love theater what theater oh it wasn't
oh that's so good what private jet
company are you guys using I'm not
private jetting I'm just saying that
would be another what theater I could
you are more famous than we are yeah no
doubt yeah well I preach by a million
but uh no no there's zero complaints
coming from this guy I got stoned and I
was like yeah I was lonely I'm on the
road I'm watching I'm looking at
Facebook what
theater it was Helium Comedy Club that's
right no it's like a 500 Cedar old homes
is going out going like there's a lot of
available seats there's a lot of Elijah
at this
Passover and uh it was still very fun
and I'm still very grateful but uh you
know yeah hurts a little bit yep any
hoole I'm stoned I'm on Facebook cuz I'm
[__] just curious who's in here yep
yep yeah totally scrolling then I watch
some [__] [__] movie I watch the
unauthorized uh what what unauthorized
Melrose
Place that's so funny cuz I'm so brain
dead I have to watch something totally
stupid and I'm loving it and then
remember I'm Stone I'm not very stoned
but I'm stoned enough that I turn off
and I'm like what do I do now and I'm
like oh I'll turn the lights off lay
down and I'll just watch my mind you
know what I mean you ever get that
feeling where you're like it's the third
it's you're not stopping the
entertainment or the fun
you're just looking at the inner phone
let's see what it does yeah you have
what on a plane when it's like I I'm
only thinking about it in terms of like
entertainment and passing time okay I'll
read the book I'll I'll listen to my
music and I'm like oh yeah I'll think
for a little bit like I'll think to
myself oh I'll do some thinking as if
you're like podast it's the OG phone
what do you got especially if you're
Stone it's like remember this kid from
Camp I have you seen those uh
uh I forget what it's called but I've
seen it on Instagram where it's like a a
Darkness Retreat where it's like for 4
days you don't see light at all you're
in Pitch Black whoa and there's these
videos of the people like finally like
readjusting with these glasses or
whatever and then taking them off and
seeing the world again and I really want
to do it why because they're ecstatic
yeah because it's you go what you're
talking about of like what's in here
that's all you have 4 days in a row
wow dude I do not believe that at all
what that I want to do it no just
that people are reacting that way cuz
they're they had a horrible experience
like you're saying that they enjoyed
taking the blindfolds off of course
because it was hard as [__] and then
they take them off and they go oh my God
look at the world yeah it's like a
whatever it's called sensory deprivation
sort of yes but you'd have that same
reaction if you were locked in like a
suitcase for 4 days well that is how
they do it that is a thing yeah it's a
coffin did I not say that it's emerging
from a coffin but it's it's like
dopamine fasting it's like Vision
sensory fasting I suppose which is I buy
it I think that would be really hard it
would be horri they say like day two
they were like uh it was the most
painful thing ever because it's just
this yeah and dude have you ever been
like I encourage you to do it if you
haven't but like laying falling asleep
at night we get a chance every day to do
it and if you do it kind of deliberately
I'm like picture a light like picture a
like a a light source yeah and you can
like full white you can make it like but
like it has the sensation of a spotlight
hitting you or I've said I've said this
before but like I've been at the bottom
of a space shuttle taking off like
watching the plume and as soon as you
notice that it's happening you go and it
goes away yeah but it's like your
[__] brain is crazy and that's kind
of what I'm talking about when it comes
to a story
an example of the story would be oh the
universe is is uh is playing with itself
it's dancing with itself or or you could
say God made the world does anything
resonate with you
guys no wrong answers God Just In This
Moment not your your final answer just
today yeah vaguely like I think there is
something keeping like a narrative going
is that does that make sense like un
furling something with AER purpose or
like an arc with an arc yeah yeah and
you're a part of it I think so yeah I
mean that that feels right like
synchronicities that's that's a pretty
basic thing like have you ever been
maybe it's the week you're going out for
SNL or something and you just get these
signs these little Winks that you're
like in the flow totally and I feel like
if you wrote all those down it would be
embarrassingly long yeah yeah totally
it's a phenomenon that we're all bored
with or or it's inconvenient you're like
I don't know what to make of that I
going back to the St war of art it's
like the Muse feels really spiritual to
me like whenever we're on a run I'm like
that can't be me yeah like that's
something else when you say I'm getting
out of my way and the idea comes in well
who is getting out of what's way and
still in you yeah you guys know from
listening to this pod that's the way
that most people that are atheistic
leaning they still concede that there
there's a flow place where something
wanted like the yearning there's a
yearning and it wants to come through
you and that's a Steven pressfield thing
too is like you might have an idea and
if you don't do it someone else will do
it like that happens all the time and
it's almost like these things are
floating around and then they they kind
of you either say yes to them or you
don't I like the fishing metaphor that
the David Lynch like is that what he
says yeah you have to like show up and
wait for the idea like you have to if
you don't go to the lake and fish for it
you'll never catch any yeah I love that
and Alan wats has the a lake thing too
where he's like you have to get the
water still and let all the sediment
fall and that might just be breathing or
walking or basketball honestly something
that gets all that noise out of the way
you know what's the thing that I've been
thinking
about um that I just don't understand
tell me the UN you are the universe
experiencing itself yeah what is that
what does that mean
yes I mean another way to say that CU
I'm one of those people is that there's
nothing personal about being we're all
like vessels of awareness uh and then
they're personalized in these packages
but that awareness is what the universe
is meaning this room is made of like
consider that if you did close your eyes
and you touch this you make a story that
oh there's a chair here but what's
really [__] happening get like honest
scientifically honest there's a
sensation that that appears in your
awareness you know what I'm saying like
there's a there's a screen and you could
see it like data like like like a like
sand on a speaker like it's it uh jumps
up when you touch this but like Is that
real the universe is made out of
perception yeah yeah and so when we say
what is left when you remove all the
data that the perception is perceiving
you might call that being itself pure
awareness you could call it God or like
whatever whatever floats your but
there's a real comfort in going like
Pete's [__] but that thing is okay
like that thing doesn't have any fear or
Panic or dread and and the more you can
move your investment your identity from
Pete yeah which sometimes he's Richard
Simmons bombing sometimes he's killing
okay fine it's it's it's always changing
it's always in flux what what was
consistent rert spy would say the screen
the screen on which everything appeared
is the same whether you're tripping
balls whether you're drunk having sex
killing bombing alone together it's it's
a Still Point yeah moving is you know
this sounds like we're stoned but it's
like it's an illusion like you you go to
London it's still the same [__] thing
just everything on the screen changed
with the screen so spirituality is the
the I would say one way to think of
spirituality is removing fear anxiety by
Mo shifting your identity from the
characters in the movie to the
screen can you repeat that you can
listen to it again on half speed oh but
I didn't question another way of saying
what you were saying like I'm the
universe experiencing itself you could
say I am the eyes of the universe
looking at myself meaning there's a very
simple practical thing thing and it can
lead to paranoia but most of these ideas
can you're on an airplane looking out
the window everyone else's windows are
closed in that moment you're the you're
giving reality to that cloud right
you're the one seeing it so appreciation
and experience is a way of loving and
and giving validity the reason that can
lead to paranoia like we close our
everyone closes their eyes are we here
thing right yeah it gets a little weird
it's such a weird thing the reason why I
ask is just because it's like that has
always resonated with me and I just
can't visualize it yeah you know what I
mean but that made sense to me I think I
I would say Rupert spy is a really great
non-religious language he doesn't even
say God he's just saying the most
important question is what is it that's
aware of my experience yeah and he goes
no one asks that MH like just what is it
not who is it yeah oh it's [__] John
John
we gave you that something gave you that
we're pretending that it's normal to be
John but like the the quality of
something that knows that it's feeling
something hearing something tasting
something remembering something memory
is [__] crazy remember when you went
to the bathroom remember my bathroom how
are you doing that yeah like where did
you find that yeah and and when you get
to the humble side of science I'm all
for science but when science can't and I
I'm not saying this to point a finger
I'm just saying
it's a pretty big blank area in in
science science that that we don't know
how we are observing so you're looking
in a microscope and you get data but you
don't know what it is or or you don't
know yet you could say what it is
exactly or you can't quantify or
reproduce what it is that's looking in
the microscope that's a pretty yeah
that's why I think scientific arrogance
is funny like you don't know what it was
that observed what you observed right
anyway I'm on a tear I love it I love it
get [__] stoned and listen to this
again oh my God Martin anything I see
you I see you shimmering no uh I I I
really don't think about it ever uh and
I think I I grew up uh very Catholic Al
Boy nine years yeah so I feel like the
you know like the second I start
thinking about stuff like this I'm like
oh like Pascal's wager type
stuff of like I don't know I I just know
that I'm going to end
up becoming Catholic again like it just
feels so deep in me that is and I want
to put that off I would love to do that
when I'm 70 as that's exactly what
melany said he goes I was raised
Catholic I don't believe anything now
but I know in the future I will be very
Catholic that's just how it goes and I
actually think you don't need my
validation but for what it's worth I'm
like that's right on schedule it would
be weird if you guys again I'm almost
dead but like it's
there and I I I think it's nice to have
these conversations just to remind
ourselves that you by virtue of existing
get a seat at the table and get to have
a perspective yeah you don't have to
have a masters in Divinity or you don't
even need to read these books you can
just go like it's like falling asleep
and going can I picture a light yeah
like just getting curious about it with
your iic you know icon clastic
perspective that's a that's a a help in
looking at the meaning of life and
rejecting all that stuff is all or or
even taking a break from all that stuff
is is super good yeah I think yeah I
love it TM helps with that too do you uh
meds I haven't you meds meds meditation
I uh I did it for a long time and then
like fell off kind of SNL because like
any chance that I got I would just nap
instead yeah but I'm slowly and so once
once you got High SNL you start drinking
again stop again stop meditating uh I
gotta say I sorry to be advice guy but
whim doing wimh off if you go on YouTube
and just type in three rounds of Wim Hof
y I don't think there's anything it's
like taking 15 xanas I know it's crazy
and then you're like I do it before I go
on stage yeah I my U wonderful opener
Matt is on stage I have 25 minutes I do
three rounds and I don't even push it
and I go on stage and I'm just like
[__] you're there I'm so there and my
body is regulated and all that stuff the
breathing stuff is amazing how I would
Breathe before I'd meditate these days
that's all I meant sorry yeah well it's
like you just feel it immediately yeah
like TM even on like good sessions like
oh I kind of feel it yeah you know what
I mean but breathing exercises really
are just like oh and you can do it
[__] bad yeah like and still helps
and it still helps that's what I mean
and and this I I don't mean to be
putting down meditation but like I don't
know know for my money it's like it's
been helping me more I'll give you these
this is first person it is a sponsor but
I'm going to give you guys some of this
first person it boosts uh oxytocin which
is the Feelgood chemicals it's all just
mushrooms and dopamine which is the
motivating chemical it's [__] nuts
I'll give each of you some of that it's
really like if because what I'm
realizing is first person aside how I
feel yeah is so important to creating if
I'm on stage or if I'm just trying to
you guys are jamming like I need to get
my every every hack I can do breathing
supplements whatever to get myself in a
state that sleepover state where you're
happy safe and regulated this is these
are conversations Chevy Chase was not
talking about having a regulated body
you know what I'm saying but if you're
in your dressing room and you're feeling
overwhelmed you just put your hand on
your chest and sigh five times like it's
such a [__] privilege to live in a
world where you can go is your body
regulated yeah is your [__] body
regulated do it it helps I don't I don't
know why I got into advice mode but I I
I love you guys and I want I want to
give you what I got absolutely we love
you dude I love you I really mean it I
think you guys are fantastic and whether
or not you have anything coming
up I'm excited for
it who's to say who's to say I certainly
don't know can we end because I couldn't
your [__] wikkipedia
page says that your name is based on an
act that's what it says an act called
please don't destroy our farm we had we
started a show track what' you say no
I'm trying to figure out what act means
act a show I guess oh a show Martin and
I started a standup show at the end of
college for me Martin was a freshman uh
called please don't destroy my farm
where I was an evil businessman and he
was a farm we were like it's a standup
show but we were weaving this narrative
in between like regular like Club
standup comedians but doing like crazy
so funny it's perfect like let's do a
comedy and it's so high concept and
shitty it is so I it's just took me back
that just took me back I did want to
talk to you and I regret not talking
about it more but like about rifi era in
New York like I'm obsessed with that I'm
so glad it's worthy of a of Obsession
only because I'm like so few things that
I get to be a part of but I was like
there and we knew we were there totally
I think this is happening and I always
showed up too late and I actually got
there at the at the right time
everything was closing everything like
[__] um what was it called twinkle
there something Luna Lounge Luna Lounge
eating it at Luna Lounge ended right
when I got to all these all things were
ending but like rafif was just getting
started so cool God we just didn't have
like a place like that yeah yeah you
guys would have loved it cuz they show
videos they would have loved please
don't destroy our farm yeah weird weird
standup yeah but also you know that's
all just blurred together I I mean we
have a little time we're not at two
hours right is there any rifi question
or thought I mean I'm just like so
interested in that era like I I've
listened to the like invite them up
album so many times and uh so [__]
crazy I'm on that aren't I yeah I think
so I think I have like a f I think I do
30 seconds of stand up that's yeah which
was a big deal for me cuz I was like I
got in not even in a status way I just
wanted to be because it was Eugene and
it was Bobby and it was [__] hip and
I I just shown up so to do the 30
seconds was really really cool that was
a thing they did where you got to do
stand up for 30 seconds yeah yeah which
was really really fun but it was like
like oh hello started there and like
like I feel like Joe Mandy had a show
there and totally JK did you did you
host a show there or did you just went
up there I they had a show Jesse kleene
and Nick koll had a show called Welcome
to our week which was on Monday night
and I found about it by by reading the
Village Voice wow and I thought the way
it was described I was picturing like a
slick talk show yeah and you get there
and it's like just a black box you know
it smells like someone just spilled a
beer you know what I mean it's dark and
weird and there were like it was sparse
it I mean I love talking about it too
that's it's a generous topic for you to
bring up but it's like you know there's
15 people there it says probably 50
there's 15 people watching Nick koll and
John meany do oh hello yeah which I
resent like I when people are like that
was just gold it was gold I'm like I
watch that struggle you [__] and that's
my point that's my point is it's like
it's not embarrassing to say it didn't
smash right away that's and I don't mean
it was was like embarrassing or bad I
just mean there were 12 people there so
they had to believe in it more than the
response I mean it still did very well
it was very funny but watching that come
together so cool we totally tried to
like recreate that energy at that did
you ever go to vau it's like not a lot
of shows happened there but it's on
bleer and that was like right before the
pandemic we started doing a weekly show
there where we would do like six brand
new sketches every week see sister
I'm sorry you're like I regret breaking
up
system and that's what like I feel like
for people listening that want to do
sketch want to do comedy group like
having a routine we perform on this
night and we have a goal so simple and
we're going to meet every day y The
Whitest Kids did that at posan yep yeah
and obviously John and Nick did it at
rifi but like you need to be on a
Highwire no one we're fight flight
freeze cre features and that's why
Lauren's model works and that's why fake
deadlines work that's why it's [__]
you don't have to do six new schedule
but you make you're meaning making
machines that go we said we were going
to do it yeah and that's the difference
now I really sound like [__] Tim
Ferris but I love Tim Ferris it's like
that's the difference between making and
moving forward and and not is like
making sort of nonsense Stakes but
taking them very seriously yeah there's
no difference between fake rules and
real rules
because there are no real rules that's
exactly right that's exactly right and
it was good because doing that it was
like everybody would bring in two it
sketches is a very like generous term
for what they were it was like an idea
yeah and you just had to figure it out
on stage yeah and it was so helpful I I
[__] look to close in the same
compliment that I started with watching
you guys here today and and watching
your stuff I'm just like it just refuels
me it just makes so excited about comedy
and being silly and and making it work
you guys are [__] inspiring I
appreciate you we love you dude love you
man this is great Martin thank you did
you say he said oh love
you um we love you man we love you
thanks um all right what is the hardest
you've ever
laughed we had one yesterday with who me
and V yeah my daughter was watching the
iPad uh I'd say regrettably but guys we
need a break we need a break she's on
the pad and I was wearing a pair of
underwear I don't normally wear meaning
they they're kind of lower in the box
and I pulled them up Midway so I sort of
had Manel toe mammal toe camel toe for
men yeah moose knuckle moose knuckle
yeah that's what my old boss said
whatever he would do this same bit so
I'm toing I like I said I was not
selling out St Louis and or not selling
Out Raleigh excuse me it's hard to keep
track of which city I'm not selling out
and I'm in my living room and I missed
Val so much and I was in my underwear
and I was I don't know I was going
upstairs to shower but instead I pulled
my pants up and had moose knuckle and
just started doing a roast of how she
loves Brett Goldstein yeah and I was
like Brett Goldstein is over he's going
to be Irrelevant in like five years oh
you that fit get the [__] out of here
we're going to be tired of you
and I was going this is the new sexy and
I started clapping my elbows onto my
skin and it would make like an
embarrassing Clapp on sound here's the
key John just John Val didn't know all
of
you it she wasn't laughing at first
that's key like it wasn't she wasn't in
the she was like writing an email or
something and I kept doing it and just
going like this is the new sex walking
back and forth like a windup toy
and she started crying laughing which
made me cry laugh and I could tell in
the quality of her laugh she actually
was embarrassed like of me like it
wasn't just you got me it actually was
she said I did the least sexy thing
that's ever happened while roasting the
sexiest thing and that's that's the uh
what's the that's the observation yeah
like what if I was just going this but
it was pure it's kind of the compliment
I'm giving you guys' work it's like
being silly is so undervalued and when
you can actually step right in the Bulls
ey and it'll never happen again it it
wasn't for anything that was my hardest
laugh this week good that's good what
what do you guys got any hardest laugh
stories
uh one of my favorites was something
John said uh which was he was describing
this guy who's like a family friend of
yours and I remembered that the last
well you were describing him and you
were like he's he's the type of guy
who's always just like he'll show up and
he's just like eating some
dumplings and and I was like the last
time we saw him he was eating dumplings
and that's why you're saying that but he
made it his whole charact why is he like
the type of dude who's always just like
eating [__] dumplings that I was high
correct it made me die both of you guys
you like you just saw him eating
dumplings
once he's always just like you eating
dumpling I don't know if you've heard me
talk about my dad being that way my dad
will be my dad will see like a
firefighter relaxing on a Tuesday and
he'll be like I don't think they fight
FES on
Tuesday blow up but like that same
quality is incredibly useful in like
minimizing this chaotic
world
that's what that is you're one of those
you're a dumpling guy what you're really
saying is I'm scared I don't know you
but I know you like dumplings and my
brain calms down when it can say you
mean the dumpling guy dumpling guy I
used to do with all of Val's friends I'd
go big head yeah big head and she's like
okay and I go seaweed hair seaweed hair
and big head okay easy like what are you
doing yeah it's a it's a like comedy is
like the good use of that type of Jing
uh I love that oh get this boy some
dumplings uh that was a that was so loud
I'm so sorry I laugh it's weird that
that's not more embarrassing like farts
are mortifying but your stomach can like
be like
Contracting like [__] Jaba dying and
do you guys get that oh JK um anybody
else Jaba dying the Hut yes who needs
the Hut there's a good stand up there
yeah who needs the Hut that's good we're
going to
jabas that's really [__] the hot yeah
bumping M Che M the hardest I laugh is
when it's like a really happy thing and
I'm I'm laughing it so hard at how
joyous yeah uh it is and there was the
season 4 of
succession when it came out my fiance
and I were in bed watching it and when
the theme song came in we both
involuntarily started going yes and we
got so into the theme song and we were
so happy that I was I just couldn't stop
laughing cuz we were just like this this
is it like yes is there anything better
than that what you just said and it is a
great song to go like
this it's like did you hear Kanye and
Jay-Z played the succession theme song
12 times at this show like no one would
be mad no it's [__] awesome I say it
to too much but it does it slaps it's a
and it's funny that we all looked
forward to a show that gave us PTSD yeah
we're like I can't wait so good
Marty
this uh it's just happened this morning
but uh anytime I girl oh we have to go
no no no it looked like he was watch he
was miking
his mine is going too yeah uh whenever
my girlfriend she'll be like sitting
some and start laughing be on her phone
and start laughing really hard and I'll
come around to see what it is thinking
that it's you know some piece of Comedy
or something and it's always like a a
gorilla with like big
eyes you
know and she's crying and that'll make
me like cry laughing that's so awesome C
that's just so sweet it is sweet you
sometimes look over the fence and you go
like some people they just need a
gorilla with big eyes yeah and me too
now now my feet is like a monkey falling
over and I'm like oh man since Instagram
has stopped asking you to follow people
like it just starts showing you stuff
that you don't follow yeah I'm like it
should have been doing this the whole
time I know like that is literally
genius cuz it turns out I want guys
playing the piano to a a cat meowing
yeah like it's
like and I'm like I watch it nine times
and then I'm too em no I did follow that
guy but sometimes I'm like I don't want
to follow a mom advice meme thing but I
do and it knows cuz it knows how long
you Linger on it and all that stuff and
like I'm like [__] fine [__] fine
I saw take it a still picture of an
oranga Tang throwing a posum yes yes
dude that made me cry was itl yeah yeah
it climbed up like the it there's a
video of it too yeah dude I'm really big
into the monkey [__] as well [__]
I love monkeys why did he throw it
because it was in its territory so like
AUM got in and climbed up a thing and he
like notices it and [__] charges up
and is like NOP just Chucks it out CHS
it out of the it's so funny how we're
always like look to the animals look to
the animals just be present like a bear
Matt and that just killed a family just
killed a family everybody's like kids
are so pure and innocent and Matt and
Trey are always like no they're not like
they're evil they're they're absolutely
delivered fully fresh cooked they're
here I said to my daughter the other day
I go she's like why can't I get a toy
every time I go whatever to Target I'm
like cuz Bubba like things don't make us
happy like I'm trying to show you that
you know you get things she goes but
they
do she goes I want to swim in toys she's
never seen Ducktails she's never seen
Ducktails swimming toys it's just honest
yep I mean that's what you can hand to
animals and kids it's honest we all want
to throw that is pure our mother-in-laws
get
the the least relatable 80s reference
and I love my mother-in-law all right
let's dedicate this to Beth Cheney I'm
just kidding that's my mother-in-law um
would you guys say keep it crispy I mean
how how are we going to do it all three
at once one at I think you should do one
at at a time and then all three once
okay ready keep you're saying oh one
word I like that
here what we do keep it crispy keep it
crispy keep it crispy keep it crispy
then all three keep that's too much
that's too
much keep it crispy and then all at once
keep oh that's it that's right ready see
tape cut keep it crispy keep it crispy
from please come don't
disturb on our farm wait one last thing
we did uh our coolest show we came out
to LA for our first time we did the show
called good heroin which was we were so
psyched to don't say the name of it oh
why not that's fine and the the I think
Matt or somebody was bringing us up we
love these guys they're coming all the
way from New York City put your hands
together but please don't stop and we
were like [__] they're such Friends of
the show you know them you love them
that is please don't stop
just not even close that is me and Matt
do that all the time we go he's a close
personal friend of mine bringing me up
we love him he's here all the time give
it up for Pat Helms everybody so we
still uh Say pat Helms got it love it
need it guys thank you pleas don't
destroy love you our farm love you thank
you Kati love
you made it you made it you made it all
yeah you made it you made it you made it
with oh yeah you made it with
you made it you made it with oh yeah you
made it you made it you made it with all
yeah